a daring dangerous escape masterminded
in desperation enslaved ellen and
william kraft fled america in 1850
hidden in disguise
top hat cravat and ellen's fair skin
tone allowed her to masquerade as a
white man with william as her servant
their great escape lives on through
their descendants
they covered almost every base when it
came to ways of how they could be caught
so they had
they couldn't write
so she had a sling on
which means that someone wanted her sign
her name
she wouldn't be able to because she
would have been right-handed
and she couldn't she couldn't
and it worked they settled here in west
london in a house now stamped with blue
ceramic it celebrates their legacy as
freedom fighters and fierce anti-slavery
campaigners even their relatives are
overwhelmed by their fortitude i think
their story is not extraordinary i think
it's almost unbelievable when i first
heard of it i thought this is like a
work of fiction somebody's made this up
beggars belief
and of course the fact that you know
i've got their dna inside me you imagine
how proud that makes me
there are some
975 blue plaques across london but only
41 on a black and asian people including
the crafts it's an imbalance many are
keen to address but it's not always easy
musician bob marley lived here in 1977
but it took a long time to prove it's
often this lack of historical records
that's preventing more stories from
being recognized
certainly is an issue for ethnic
minorities and for the poor
because what it can mean is that it's
difficult to track down
evidence that will connect a person to a
building it might be that a building's
been destroyed or it might be that the
records that do exist are not
sufficiently compelling
but records are becoming more accessible
with advancing technology so that
dedication access and will can be the
ingredients to uncover more hidden
figures in history ash and haranag sky
news in central london